in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Jennifer is with us Merry Christmas
Jennifer merry Christmas to you Dave
where are you from I'm from Spring Texas
which is where it's near Houston okay
north of Houston yeah cool well welcome
to Nashville thank you
and all the way over here to do your dad
free scream yes I love it
congratulations how much of your paid
off two hundred and sixty two thousand
dollars goodness gracious how long did
that take took about fifteen months but
that included a house as well okay did
you sell the house I did but so my
story's a little bit different um my
husband and I had started this journey
in January of 2015
and we were doing our budget which was
ridiculous to have to to do a budget it
was hard but my husband was actually
sick he was on a liver transplant list
and we were just we had took your advice
and sold some stock and enough to pay
off all of our debt with the exception
of our house and he was getting close to
needing the transplant and so I begged
him please let's just wait we're going
to do Dave Ramsey we need to do it right
and so we we just stopped we stopped the
debt snowball and we started um you know
just saving for a um the storm that we
were in yeah which is what you showed up
done yeah yeah so we actually came to
Nashville in May of last year for him to
have his transplant and we had actually
come to see you about ten days after the
transplants and you know we're so
excited we will be back to door
debt-free scream mm-hmm unfortunately
after needing a second transplant my
husband passed away July fourth of that
year so um but I'm finishing what we
started so um a big portion of you know
of the debt of course was paid off with
life insurance but I did sell our home
but not because I had to but I did it to
downsize and then I bought a a smaller
house about eight tenths of a mile from
from the other house but
so that's that's my story as far as how
the debt was paid off so he passed when
July 4th of 2015 15 yes all right
so the picture they just showed of you
and me and him was when you guys visited
right after he had his first tranche yes
that is correct you guys came by here
yes and we were so excited to come and
tell you that hey we're doing your plan
and we're gonna be there and yeah we we
are in a storm but we'll be back to do
the debt-free screen so um I'm so sorry
yeah how so
18 months basically now I know yeah yeah
and how long were you guys married we
were married for five years Wow Wow
okay so uh did you have a lot of
discussions with him about this stuff I
know you talked about a lot of stuff
yeah I just health was failing I'm sure
you know um we didn't talk about death
because we you know we thought his hope
was a transplant and so we really never
talked about you know what if what if um
I mean our goal was you know pay off the
debt mm-hmm you know live and give like
no one else so okay and so how are you
doing
I'm okay I'm I'm very fortunate that I'm
have a big support group of friends and
family mm-hmm oh she had a policy with
who's with you so um the Reese's brand
cami restore my next-door neighbors that
actually got us started on financial
peace and then my good friend Chad and
they're here came all the way from Texas
to support me oh yeah so I'm very
grateful for them because they nagged us
every day you need to do Dave Ramsey you
know you need to do this but the thought
of doing a budget yeah and that just
really wasn't something that you know
Craig and I we're really familiar with
but then to look at how much money we
actually made and brought home and how
much money we spent we didn't know where
it went and a lot of that went to eating
out yeah a lot of it so how are you you
got enough life insurance to pay off the
house and are you set now I am okay all
right and you're in your living in
control with your budget I am no grief
spending well I did some grief spending
and then I would so I would if I would
take a long trip you know just in the
car maybe a few hours and I would be
listening to some of your calls and
stuff when it got to the debt-free
screams I would just cry like a baby but
sure yeah because I I was there I was
ten free but you know was eventually
going to be there and but didn't have
that person to to scream it with I was
our that was our goal but mid-90s
I am yeah because there were some times
that you would say some things like okay
you know what you have you need to go
through that you need to go through that
process
and then get back on track so yeah you
medicate a little but if you know you
just don't overmedicate yes don't watch
out of control no no I am I'm in control
okay cool cool I don't have a lot of
purses to sell hahaha
David not agree you don't have a meal to
marco's shoe collection there no I don't
you got to be old even know who that is
I'm not sure I'm probably old enough
knew that Israel I really don't know it
is okay it was a famous uh she was like
the president of Philippines or
something she had like a million shoes
it was ridiculous back thirty years ago
anyway yeah so yeah shoe collection
but anyway Wow well you're brave to get
up here and do this is the last thing
that I needed to do just to finish kind
of what we had started no I was
important well it was important to him
obviously and to you and you're set on
the track now that wasn't one you wanted
to be on but um but at least it's I then
the Train is on the track it's in
control and and you've got some
directions some things you can do and if
you need anything you know we'll walk
with you
I appreciate that well well
congratulations on being debt-free I'm
sure we should have been any other way I
did say I would add it to but we'll
we'll definitely celebrate anyway
because that's what he would have wanted
I'm sure so very cool all right Jennifer
from Houston two hundred and sixty two
thousand dollars paid off in 15 months
that's the house and everything counted
down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one Craig we're debt-free
congratulations darling Wow amazing hmm
ah you know I started doing this talk
radio show it's coming up on 25 years
ago and I thought I was going to be
talking to people about how to do a
mutual fund or you know how to buy a car
and I get ripped off or something and
now I find myself talking to somebody
like Jennifer you don't hear this kind
of thing happening on other shows I'll
just tell you this kind of authenticity
this kind of people getting real and
telling their what's really going on in
their life unbelievable Wow
what a story and you know what that's
the thing about financial principles
it's the thing about all principles that
are truth principles the truth works
when things are good and the truth works
when things are bad the idea of being
out of debt causes you to prosper when
things are good the idea being out of
debt causes you to survive when things
are bad gives you a different comfort
level the idea of being on a written
plan causes you to prosper with your
budget when your things are good causes
you to survive when things aren't so
good the idea of saving money causes you
to prosper you following what I'm saying
here the idea of giving causes you to
prosper when things are good and when
things are bad that's the thing about
the truth is it works no matter the
circumstances and I wish I could say
that's the only time I've had a picture
made with someone and then they're not
here now they're in heaven but I'm
afraid I've got a lot of those pictures
over the years of doing this
and it just causes you to stop and
remember that these this is real we're
not we're not playing around here this
is your life it's a real thing you're
living it's a real thing we're doing
here with the show and thank you for
listening and for participating you can
pray for Jennifer if you want wouldn't
make her mad or me mad this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]